Luke here at the outo boys YouTube
channel and we're back for another
Homestead Adventure few months ago I
bought this Homestead and found that it
was full of abandoned equipment
equipment's been breaking down buildings
have been catching on fire and we've
been breaking our backs trying to build
a road through the swamp but I've got a
feeling now things are about to turn a
corner well it's been several weeks
since I figured out the road I was
building wasn't completely on my
property and I have to admit that was a
bit of a low point
however I figured out a solution to my
problems so I went to the tax records
and figured out who owned the property
that my road was on and I went to the
owner and explained to him what I did I
said I would move the road buy an
easement or buy their property outright
so now I own two properties in the
interior of Alaska while this was not
what I was originally planning I think
it might be a blessing in disguise all
this money I've spent improving this
Trail is is going to raise the property
values of all the properties that need
this Trail for Access so now I've just
doubled my investment at least that's
what I told my
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wife got a friend here who's going to
give us a
ride well for the last week we've been
having a neighbor M digging gravel out
of this Hillside stock pilot so we can
put it on top of that bone rock that
we've been laying down now this material
has a lot of clay in it so it doesn't
drain water very well and can get really
muddy and soupy but the bone Rock drains
water really well so when you put this
on top of the bone rock it keeps the
bone Rock from moving around and the
bone Rock helps keep this
dry what do you think it's good to see
isn't it so much better
we get that clay with rocks in it over
the top and this will be a joy to walk
on thank you
so sorry man I hope I wasn't keeping you
waiting well guys I uh I might have done
some therapeutic shopping I bought
myself an imported Japanese K
truck this is a four-wheel drive Suzuki
carry and it's uh been modified for
Alaska this is by Japanese K truck it's
got allterrain treads on it incredible
amount of ground clearance it's got
four-wheel drive high and low off-road
lights and it's got an oil pan and
engine block heater and of course an
extra tall cab on the back and this
thing is imported from Japan so uh the
steering wheel's on the right hand
side big man in a little truck look
Becca I'm a truck guy
now
is it true that women find pickup guys
more sexy cuz looking good yeah it's
lifted
too oh it's pretty
cute actually can I sit in it real fast
I haven't been in it
yet it's got loads of head room but it's
a little tight in the legs isn't it cute
cute it's got heat in AC and a
radio and it'll keep the bugs out that's
a big one mhm don't lose the keys we're
making progress aren't we yes I can tell
a big big difference and I love the
truck but I think that's all we're going
to get done for today I think we need to
go pick up the kids yeah we
[Music]
[Applause]
do oh this is so much smoother than the
side by side this thing rides like a
dream there's a grous right there we
might have to come back and do some
hunting
well check it out guys my road is
finished look at this nice soft gravel
on top of the washed rocks we're going
to go take the truck down the trail and
see how it
does well there we go we've got a
road I'll tell you what the road feels
pretty solid in the end it cost me about
$155,000 to build this Trail that's a
lot of money but the alternative is
buying a fleet of Argos and a brand new
Argo will cost you 20 to $30,000 but
thanks to this road I can now access my
property with just about any ATV all
year
round one of the first things I want to
do today is get my electrical system up
and running something happened to my
batteries and they drained so completely
that the solar panels can't charge them
anymore so I got this charger and I'm
going to hook them up to my batteries
and hook it up to the generator and see
if we can't jump start our
batteries well I'm going to go ahead and
let that run for a couple hours and see
if it doesn't charge up the
batteries a look at all this stuff I
brought and I didn't have to carry it
off my back this is so much
easier as soon as the snow starts
falling everything out here is going to
get buried so everything that's out in
this yard needs to get put away or
thrown away and now that I have the road
in the truck I can do
that well a lot of the stuff I'm
throwing away could be pretty useful to
some of my neighbors so I called them up
and said hey if you want it come and get
it and now that I got my road they can
come and get it hey Jay
well thanks maned for taking that stuff
off my hands thank
you there you
go all right let's see if this
works charging this battery for an hour
and a half and it still won't even turn
on on its own something is not right
this one will actually turn
on
it's probably going to take about two
hours round trip to get one load of
garbage to the dump 2 hours
later let's see if it'll work now let's
see if we got any
power oh well I still got a lot to
figure out with that electrical system
One battery seems broken and the other
one's charging up but for now I've got
electricity running off off the
generator so I'm not going to be eating
in the dark tonight that's that's
nice a all right we got
heat you know I've got this giant
television up here and I have no idea if
it works or
not oh there's a DVD in
there okay I just noticed that there is
a soundbar sitting here against the wall
held up with duct
[Music]
tape I wonder if I can get this speaker
working though I think this is a
Bluetooth speaker okay let's
[Music]
see
here let's move this over here well haa
we've got an entertainment system we
found this box fan here want to see if
it works sure does okay is I want to set
this box fan up in the ceiling to push
the hot air
down oh yeah it is just roasting hot up
here got a Jerry rig this box fan to
blow straight
down this whole situation is a bit of a
hot
B all right good let me show you what we
[Music]
got water jug is so
dirty it's basically a battery powered
sprayer with a 3 and 1/2 gallon tank you
just just charge it up pour some water
in it and you can take it anywhere the
previous owners been trying to get
running water in here as well they
bought a water tank and a water heater
they had a pressure tank and they'
installed a whole bunch of Plumbing but
we still don't have running water in the
cabin and the reason is really simple
the cold this water heater was
completely destroyed by ice so before
the heat ever goes off you have to drain
your entire water system or you're going
to destroy all your plumbing and that's
a major pain in the butt especially for
someone like me who's only using this on
the weekend instead I bought this thing
and it's cheaper less hassle and when
you need to winterize it you just dump
all the water out and spray it till you
get
air that battery is fully charged now so
let's see if we can run the house off
it aha so right now the cabin's
electricity is running completely off
that one battery awesome that is perfect
all right guys I got a bowl of peanuts I
think it's time to sit down and watch
watch a
movie
SE tired and I got to get to bed I've
got a lot of work tomorrow so I'll see
you guys in the
morning well good morning I really am
enjoying being able to flip switches and
get heat and
light
well guys we had a little surprise last
night look at this when I told you I
need to clean up before the snow berries
everything I wasn't
joking oh boy we got to hurry up and get
stuff done
today
oh I think it's time to get to
work let's see what the batter is doing
that's pretty good we've only lost about
2 volts since last night battery seems
to be handling the load pretty
well my neighbor said he would take all
this scrap metal so I'm just going to
make a big pile of it and he's going to
come and get it as he
can now you see how the previous owners
leaned wood up against the skirt of the
cabin there's two reasons for that in
the summer it keeps the porcupines out
from underneath your cabin cuz they like
to chew stuff up and they can cause a
horrible mess and in the winter time it
keeps the wind from blowing underneath
your cabin which will make it
warmer
[Music]
got some old diesel fuel here diesel
fuel tends not to blow up in your face
like gasoline it's a bit of a waste but
it's 2 hours and $20 to take that to the
landfill man look at that that burn
barrel got so hot it melted that folded
right over on
itself I want to make a little spot for
me to be able to turn the truck
around
I think it's time to go take a load of
garbage to the dump got to climb up into
my big lifted pickup there something the
women like about pick up
man oh my poor little UTV I think what
I'm going to do is tow it out of here
once it freezes up but in the meantime I
need to kind of get it out of the way
and get it covered up so it doesn't get
ruined by the
snow
[Music]
that worked better than
expected yeah this thing's a bit of an
eyesore I think we should move
it
want to check on the battery here I'm
going to go ahead and charge this sucker
up while that's running I'm going to get
some lunch
I had my hot dog sitting on the front
porch to keep them cool looks like a
little leming got in there and nibbled
the ends of them we're going to cut that
part
off oh little cheddar hot dogs are so
good oh that was good well today's a
little bit of a special day my wife and
three boys are coming up to Camp with me
tonight and if things go well we might
do a little bit of hunting too but I got
a few things to do to make things a
little bit more comfy well putting a fan
up there has really improved the
temperature in this cabin it's kept the
Loft from getting too hot and it's kept
the floor from getting too cold but
dangling the fan off the edge of the
Loft isn't a really good long-term
solution the minute I turned on that
power saw I just lost electricity to the
whole cabin it's acting like I blew a
fuse that's on that's on that's
on that's
on what was that well that wasn't good I
just saw Sparks up there yeah that
that's not good when I reset all the
breakers in there there was Sparks
coming out of the ceiling so yeah I need
to do something with that that's not
right but just one thing at a time I got
to finish this
project well this is where I'd like the
boys to sleep but it's a little bit dark
up here so I'm going to try to make it a
little bit more cozy for them so I found
a string of Christmas lights in the shed
they're a little bit melted from the
fire but uh let's see if they
work oh
that's nothing to brag about but I think
the boys will enjoy
it all right let's cook some
dinner okay here's our pantry put a bag
of
lentils
I've got to get going I got to be
becking the kids at the
car going my way yeah you want to help
me go get water yeah let's do it let's
go get water all
right it's 10 cents a
gallon but it's not
not this
out yeah you guys can sit down on the
luggage you guys good back
here oh here allow me oh my
ex
exting you can see him back
there I like the truck that was fun it
actually was really smooth it's a nice
ride isn't it it's better than a
four-wheeler yeah
here guys come on in make sure to put
your money boots in the tray okay I just
put your boots in Jack you want to see
something hey Dad
um see look at
that see I thought it'd be a little bit
less spooky to sleep up here if there
was Christmas light why don't you guys
go and make your beds up okay
yes oh bega did you bring sheets I did
nice
who wants popcorn me all right I'll make
some popcorn I
some SHP no man
down what do that do
good green apple licorice you guys want
some
yeah here guys you guys can go up there
ready for a Godzilla movie
you need use out house now that it's
getting cold we bring the toilet seat
inside keep it by the heater so it's
nice and warm then when you sit down on
it in the ouse it doesn't freeze your
butt off you ready to go use the
bathroom yeah let me feel it oh okay
everyone lay down all right guys get to
bed
okay there I need it now Becca how do
you feel about having 200 lb of me above
you
[Music]
um well guys it's late and if I don't
put this camera up the kids will never
get to sleep so I'll see you in the
morning good morning Becca good morning
you sleep warm and comfy I did I love
this sleeping bag well that's cuz it's
only A- 255 sleeping bag so you know
it's not too
warm all night who wants chocolate
pancakes
me
all right whoever wants the first
Pancake Jacob yes you want it come here
and get it oh no what did I do I'm
coming back
up all
right shall we yes we
shall oh here we go there we go got a
little bit of
metal oh you got it
it's finally hunting season we're going
to go try to shoot a grous grous like to
swallow rocks to help them digest their
food and in the winter time all the
Rocks get covered up with snow and ice
so here in the fall they come out to the
trails and the stream beds to try to
find little Pebbles to swallow so we're
going to walk up and down the trail and
see if we can't find a
gr yeah this is a giant mud hole and you
can see the people put guard rails down
yeah you can walk on the guard rails
yeah somebody made this out of actual
nailed wood the wood rots away and the
nails stay and then you can pop your
tires like little there are just miles
upon miles of trails through these woods
and once the snow falls this place
becomes a snow machiner Paradise you can
just go
anywhere there's a few cabins on these
Lakes most of those are owned by people
who have float planes or they come here
in the winter time a lot of properties
in Alaska that are only accessible by
float plane or in the winter
time me and Tommy were walking back and
there was a grous up in the tree and he
flew off this direction we're going to
go see if we can't get a shot at
him all right buddy I think we lost him
all right let's head back to the trail
he was just about 8 ft off the ground in
one of these spruce trees
it'll I'm going to go
outside all
right little Here My Dear have a see
baby this is good thank you good curries
are to beat love you
babe you want to go play with those yay
you move one space forward oh
why boom boom
shakalaka Nathan you want to go huny
all right we just scared a grous well I
should say he scared the crap out of us
and he just flew up into that tree over
there there
you well we spooked up two grous but we
couldn't get any shots at
him Becca have you had a good time I
have had a good time it's been very
relaxing how you get St to pack up we
got to get these kids
home get up in there yeah yeah walk it
you guys ready
uhhuh I'll tell you what this property
is coming along but there's still some
things we need to work on first off that
electrical system isn't working right
and I was reading on the batteries and
it says that you're not supposed to use
them if it gets cold cold like you can't
charge them below 32° F it's about to
get really cold here in Alaska so that
ain't going to fly I have got to move my
entire electrical system including the
batteries into the cabin so that I can
heat them and keep them warm while we're
using them that's going to be a big deal
plus that whole Sparks coming out of the
roof thing that's not cool yeah we got a
lot of electrical work to
do all right baby you ready let's do
this
is what do you think Becca that is a
sweet ride find me more attractive now
I'm a pickup
guy today's probably one of the last
days above freezing so I've got to spray
down the truck and spray out the tracks
so we don't have frozen mud stuck in the
gears all
winter Bea did you have a good time I
had a great time well hopefully you guys
had a good time too if you want to see
more of these Homestead videos check out
our off-grid Homestead play list I'll
put a link in the video description
below and make sure to click subscribe
I'll see you guys next
video If you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button so
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching